♪ ♪
>> THIS IS OUTNUMBERED.
I’M HARRIS FAULKNER ALONG WITH
MY COHOST, EMILY COMPAGNO,
KAYLEIGH McENANY, ALSO JOINING
US, KENNEDY AND CHARLIE HURT’S.
ARE YOU READY TO PUT THE HURTS
ON THE POLITICS?
>> ?
>> YES INDEED.
IT’S NICE TO SEE EVERYBODY’S
FACE.
>> RIGHT?
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
WE’LL GET INTO THE BIG
HEADLINES.
AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR OF
MASKING AT THE AIRPORT WE HAVE
FINALLY REACHED THIS MOMENT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> MY COMPANY ANNOUNCED THAT IF
YOU CHOOSE TO YOU MAY REMOVE
YOUR MASK.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THAT’S THE REACTION I GET
WHEN THE MOUNTAIN DEW IS FREE.
ANYWAY, PASSENGERS REJOICING
AFTER A PILOT ANNOUNCED
MIDFLIGHT THAT THE CDC’S FEDERAL
MASK MANDATE NO LONGER APPLIES.
A FEDERAL JUDGE IN FLORIDA RULED
YESTERDAY THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DID NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO CONTINUE ENFORCING
THAT MANDATE BY THE WHITE HOUSE
CALLED THE DECISION
DISAPPOINTING.
OUR OWN PETER DOOCY REMINDED
PRESS SECRETARY JEN PSAKI THAT
THE MEDIA HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
GO MASK LIST FOR WEEKS IN HER
PRESENCE.
>> YOU SAY YOU CONTINUE TO
RECOMMEND PEOPLE WEAR MASKS.
WHY IS IT THAT WE CAN SIT HERE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM
WITH NO MASK?
>> WELL, PETER, I’M NOT A
DOCTOR.
THE MASKING GUIDANCE -- THERE IS
GREEN GUIDANCE AND RIDE.
>> IT MINES ME TO FIND A WOMAN
I’M NOT A BIOLOGIST.
SHE ALSO WAS ASKED IS THE MASK
MANDATE STILL IN THE FACT?
SHE REPLIED I DON’T KNOW.
OKAY YOU THE PRESS SECRETARY AND
YOU KNOW HOW GOVERNMENT WORKS.
THE ANSWER IS WE RESPECT THE
OPINION OF THE FEDERAL JUDICIARY
BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT SHE SAYS.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION: THIS
DISAPPOINTING.
I WAS MIDFLIGHT LAST NIGHT,
MIDDLE OF MY FLIGHT THE FLIGHT
ATTENDANT SAYS BREAKING NEWS IF
YOU WANT TO TAKE OFF YOUR MASK
THEN TAKE OFF YOUR MASK.
THERE WERE CHEERS, THERE WAS
JOY.
SO IF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO EXPRESS DISAPPOINTMENT
AS AMERICA COLLECTIVELY CHAIRS,
THEY CAN TRY TO DO THAT.
BUT I HOPE JEN PSAKI AT THE
PODIUM FIGHTS VERY HARD AGAINST
THIS RULING.
I HOPE THEY SHOW THE TRUE
AUTOCRATS THAT THEY ARE.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE.
AND SHAME ON THOSE TALKING BUT
THE FEDERAL JUDGE COME I’VE MET
HER.
I’VE SPOKEN TO HER, SHE IS A
SMART WOMAN.
GO AHEAD AND GO AFTER HER, WERE
ALL CELEBRATING.
>> YOU PROBABLY SAW YOUR COHORT
ON WITH ME.
HE SAID DEMOCRATS NEED TO
RESPOND WITH THIS JUDGE IS DONE.
IF IT BECOMES A POLITICAL POND
THEY WILL NOT WIN ON THIS.
>> KENNEDY?
>> PEOPLE ARE READY TO MOVE ON.
PEOPLE IN BOTH PARTIES.
PUBLIC POLITICALLY THIS HAS BEEN
A LOSING ISSUE FOR THE DEMOCRATS
DEMOCRATS.
BUT WE SHOULD OF BEEN LIVING
UNDER THIS FOR THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF.
YOU TOUCHED ON THIS IN YOUR LAST
HOUR IF IT IS UNSAFE FOR YOU TO
COME IN CONTACT WITH A VARIETY
OF MICROBES, YOU SHOULDN’T BE
YOU SHOULD BE MASKING.
THAT IS YOUR CHOICE.
PEOPLE KNOW ENOUGH AT THIS POINT
THAT THAT’S WHAT THEY HAVE TO
DO.
BUT ARBITRARY MANDATES, THIS
JUDGE CALLED IT CAPRICIOUS, THEY
ARE IN OVERREACH OF FEDERAL
POWER.
AND A VIOLATION OF WHAT WAS
INTENDED IN THE FIRST PLACE,
WHICH WAS AN ABUSE OF THE WORD
SANITATION, WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO
REFER TO SANITIZING THINGS AND
NOT PEOPLE.
SO THIS IS HOW YOU GET INTO A
FEDERAL PICKLE.
>> ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME
HAND WASHING ROLES I’D LIKE TO
PUT INTO PLAY.
THAT WAS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
WATCHING PEOPLE WALK OUT OF OUT
PANDEMIC DURING THE PAT PAT.
>> THE BEST PICKLE I EVER GOT
INTO IS THE SAN FRANCISCO
WEARING A 22.
>> WE HAVE TIME.
GO ON, PLEASE, WE HAVE TO.
>> ARBITRARY AND CAPRICIOUS,
THAT’S A LEGAL STANDARD.
ABSOLUTELY THIS DECISION
SHOULD’VE BEEN HANDED DOWN QUITE
A LONG TIME AGO.
THIS JUDGE RULED THAT THIS
AUTHORITY WITH WAS OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE OF THIS CDC.
HAD VIOLATED THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
IT BASICALLY MEANS IS NOT WITHIN
YOUR SCOPE OF AUTHORITY AND
THAT’S NOT BASED ON SOME TYPE OF
SUPERSEDING DATA THAT MOVES IT
OUT OF THE WAY.
IT ALSO VIOLATED THE RULE MAKING
AND COMMENT.
REQUIRED BEFORE FEDERAL RULE.
NOW THERE’S A PROCEDURE SET UP
IN THIS COUNTRY WE HAVE TO
RESPECT AND THAT’S WHY THERE’S
SO MUCH POWER INVESTED IN THE
PEOPLE TO VOTE.
WE RESPECT THE PROCESS AND OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO CARRY THAT
OUT.
I FIND IT FASCINATING.
AS AN AMERICAN I AM DISAPPOINTED
BY OUR ADMINISTRATION ACTING
OUTSIDE OF OUR AUTHORITY.
LIKE EVERY OTHER FEDERAL AGENCY
UNDER THE SO-CALLED PANDEMIC
THAT IS DRAGGED ON.
>> WHEN YOU WERE DESCRIBING YOUR
CAPRICIOUSNESS YOU CAN TAKE YOUR
MASK OFF NOW, RIGHT?
LOOK HOW THE SCIENCE WENT ON A
FLIGHT, RIGHT?
OR WERE THEY NEVER REALLY PAYING
AS MUCH -- WAS THAT REALLY THE
DECIDING FACTOR OF HER FOR MANY
OF THOSE LEADERS?
ALL RIGHT.
SO WERE JUST NOW LEARNING THAT
IF YOU ARE ON AIR FORCE ONE AND
HEADED TO NEW HAMPSHIRE WITH THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE’S GOING TO
DO THE BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
TO CONTINUE PROMOTING THE THINGS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS DONE
WELL.
IF YOU ARE NOT FLIGHT YOU HAVE
TO WEAR A MASK.
>> APPARENTLY THE NEW FREEDOM
DOESN’T EXTEND TO AIR FORCE ONE.
NO, THEY CAN TRY AND DISMISS
THIS AND JEN PSAKI CAN TALK
ABOUT HOW DISAPPOINTED THE WHITE
HOUSES, BUT HOWEVER DISAPPOINTED
THEY ARE THIS RULING, THERE
DISAPPOINTED IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
ALL OF THESE RULES ARE NOT JUST
CAPRICIOUS RULES, THESE ARE
DESIGNED TO PROTECT OUR
LIBERTIES.
IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE DIFFICULT
TO TAKE PEOPLE’S LIBERTIES AWAY.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
PROCESS.
THAT’S WHY WERE ALL IN THIS
CRAZY ISLAND, BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO BE DIFFICULT.
I THINK IT’S A GREAT TIME FOR
FREEDOM.
BY THE WAY OR YOU WANT TO OR
MASK.
IT WILL PROVIDE PRECISELY THE
PROTECTION THAT AMASSED QUITE.
>> YOU KNOW, KENNEDY, WHAT WE
WERE DISCUSSING LAST HOUR ON THE
FAULKNER FOCUS, THERE WERE
PEOPLE WEARING MASKS BEFORE.
YOU CAN SEE THE ELDERLY AND SOME
WHO CAN’T GET A FLU VACCINE FOR
INSTANCE, OR CAN’T GET A WHOLE
HOST OF THINGS.
SO THEIR DOCTORS MAY TELL THEM
THAT THAT’S A GOOD IDEA FOR THEM
TO DO THAT.
BUT THIS IS ABOUT CHOICE.
I TAKE THIS AS THE SAME CATEGORY
WITH EVERYTHING ELSE THE CDC
SAYS IS A CHOICE.
THERE IS A LONG LIST.
>> I HOPE AND PRAY WHAT WE DON’T
WIND UP AS A CONTINUATION OF THE
DIVISIONS -- BECAUSE THE
DIVISIONS BETWEEN PEOPLE DOING
ONE THING AND NOT DOING THE
OTHER THING -- IT’S DURING THIS
APART AND IT’S NOT GOOD.
I GUESS WE HAVE TO REMEMBER TO
HAVE GREAT EMPATHY -- OBVIOUSLY
THERE ARE GOING TO BE FOLKS UP
OUT THERE WHO NEED TO WEAR A
MASK.
>> SOME PEOPLE WILL WEAR IT AS A
POLITICAL STATEMENT.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THAT WILL
HAPPEN?
>> AND WHAT DOES IT TELL THE
WORLD?
>> THE FACT THAT 80% OF THOSE
PASSENGERS GOING THROUGH RAKAN
AIRLINES AND D.C. ARE STILL
WEARING A MASK, I DON’T THINK
80% ARE IMMUNOCOMPROMISED.
>> AND THEY ARE CALLING FOR
BOYCOTTING THOSE AIRLINES BUT
THEY ARE TO RESPECT THE FEDERAL
JUDGE’S DECISION.
DELTA, AMERICAN COMMUNICATIVE.
>> I HOPE THEY BOYCOTT ALL OF
THEM.
ALASKA FOR EXAMPLE, THEY TOLD ME
THAT THE AIR WAS ONLY 60 SECONDS
OLD AND IT WAS THE SAFEST PLACE
TO BE POTENTIALLY, THE CLEANEST
AIR.
HEAVEN FORBID WE ARE ALLOWED TO
EXIST IN THAT LITTLE CAPSULE
WITHOUT A MASK.